est une des choses sur lesquelles il
faut insister
le mot de dépression est très souvent
très mal vécu
voyez-vous tout à l'heure
madame deghilage nous disait que n'avait
pas vue de spécialistes et qu'elle avait
employé ce mot tout récemment seulement
dans les familles dire des quelqu'un de
la famille qu'il est déprimée c'est un
peu un déshonneur en revanche quand on
trouve des ascaris quand on trouve des
hawks quand on trouve la photo ap à des
sites chronique c'est le maire qui a
restitué à la famille
ce sont tous ces fameux bouc émissaire
salvateur parce que ils viennent
introduire l'élément somatiques qui est
lui parfaitement à voir or la dépression
non seulement est parfaitement à voile
et je dirais même que pour moi dire de
quelqu'un qu'il a été déprimé c'est
presque lui rendre un hommage non pas
que je souhaite à quiconque d'être
déprimé car il n'y a pas d'épreuve plus
épouvantable que la dépression mais la
dépression existe je la rencontre tous
les jours et pour vous donner une idée
de son important je vous donner quelques
chiffres il y a en permanence dans un
pays comme le nôtre 3%
de personnes qui sont en dépression
grave 3% sas exception et million et
demi de personnes en permanence qui sont
dans les pressions g c'est-à-dire qu'ils
connaissent l'épreuve la plus
épouvantable qu'ils soient si on définit
la vérité d'une maladie par la douleur
aiguë morale la dépression est pire que
toutes les douleurs physiques je n'ai
jamais vu un malade est primé qui a été
prouvée par ailleurs son plan physique
ne pas dire mille fois la maladie
physique plutôt que ma dépression votre
grand père louis bertagna à vous en
particulier valérie pécresse que vous at
il appris à ma mère était son assistante
donc j'ai grandi effectivement après
l'école chez mes grands parents et j'ai
vu les souffrances
des malades parce que les patients
appelé au téléphone il a appelé au
téléphone et il appelait il était
souvent en grande souffrance j'ai même
assisté à une scène assez dramatique
d'un patient qui était en train de
commettre une tentative de suicide qui
passait le dernier coup de fil hamon on
perd donc pris par ma mère au téléphone
et donc c'est les moments qui vous
marque il m'a appris que les âmes devait
être réparé autant que les corps lui
c'était un médecin de l'âme il était
adoré par ses patients et surtout il a
fait reconnaître la vulnérabilité de la
dépression dans la société française il
a fait introduire avec un certain nombre
de deux collègues médecins les
médicaments pour soigner la dépression
les antidépresseurs il s'est battu toute
sa vie pour qu'on arrête de dire que
quelqu'un qui était déprimé était juste
mélancolique et devait juste se prendre
en main et c'était son combat et réparer
les âmes c'est aussi un petit peu ça la
politique est ce qu'il vous a aidé ce
qu'il à faciliter votre premier contact
avec jacques chirac non en réalité ce
qui s'est passé c'est que jacques chirac
était à terre en 97 après la dissolution
ratée de l'assemblée nationale et c'est
le moment que j'ai choisi pour lui
envoyer une lettre de candidature
donc je vais envoyer lettre de
candidature en lui disant voilà vous
êtes abandonné par tout le monde moi je
souhaite vous rejoindre j'étais à
l'époque maître des requêtes au conseil
d'état j'ai été recommandé par de noix
de sa marque était le président le
vice-président du conseil d'état à
jacques chirac mais bien sûr jacques
chirac quand il m'a rencontrée la
première fois savais que j'étais à la
fois la petite fille de mon grand père
il savait aussi que j'étais mariée un
corrézien un corrézien dont
dont la cousine était était la femme de
son suppléant henri beyle court donc
effectivement la corrèze et mon
grand-père mais c'est pas là dessus qui
a porté notre notre premier entretien
notre premier entretien à part a porté
sur deux éléments de mon cv qu'ils ont
intéressé l'internet parce que j'étais
spécialiste de l'internet et que l'ue
avait eu des problèmes avec le mulot et
le russel japonais parce que j'avais
appris le russe et le japonais et que
lui aussi était fasciné par la russie et
le japon donc on a parlé de russes on a
parlé de russie on a parlé déjà pour on
a parlé littérature est cet homme qui
était vraiment à terre politiquement à
terre je crois qu'il s'est pris
d'affection effectivement pour la jeune
femme qui venait essayer de le rejoindre
et que c'est comme ça que j'ai eus poste
[Musique]